US investigators believe Iran or groups
backed by Iran are behind attacks on
four oil tankers in the Persian Gulf
region the incidents come amid growing
tensions the New York Times reports the
White House is reviewing military plans
for a possible conflict with Iran and as
many as 120,000 US troops could be
deployed to the Middle East and the
report says the plans do not envision a
land invasion of Iran MTS Hiab is
following developments from London
India's good morning good morning well
investigations are still underway into
what exactly happened to those four oil
tankers in the Persian Gulf the United
Arab Emirates and Saudi Arabia say they
were quote sabotage with US officials
saying they believe Iran was involved
javad zarif the Iranian Foreign Minister
has denied that an accused Washington of
escalating the situation an online
maritime shipping service quoting UAE
sources is reporting that attackers used
limpet mines attached to the hulls of
the vessels although satellite images
display no major damage to the tankers
this video shows that the Norwegian
ship's hull has been visibly gouged
whatever the case there's no definitive
evidence linking Tehran to the attacks
but there are already fears the
situation could lead to an armed
conflict last week the White House
ordered additional ships and aircraft
into the region after warning of attacks
from Iran and it's proxies at this stage
there are still more questions than
answers but the concern now is that
tensions could boil over into something
far more serious this morning Iranian
backed Houthi rebels claimed to have
carried out drone attacks on Saudi
installations galle MTA's reporting from
london thank you very much